Freakier Friday is a remake of Freaky
Friday. It's been almost I think 20 25
years or something like that since the
original. You saw it, right? The
original me back to my childhood right
here. Yes. I I seen this one and then I
think there's even one prior to this. So
basically in the original Freaky Friday,
you have the mom whose name is Tess and
she's a psychologist and her her
daughter's name is Anna. She's 15. They
go to a Chinese restaurant. They're
always getting into arguments like you
know a lot of moms do when their
daughters are in their teenage years.
And uh there's this lady in the back
there who sees them arguing a Chinese
lady. She's like h I got something for
them. And so she give them a wisdom
gives them a wisdom cookie and they feel
something weird and the next day they're
swapped in each other's bodies. So and
they have to kind of like learn how to
get along and love each other and that
undo undoes the spell. So, Freakier
Friday, it just blew up on the internet.
It is a remake. Like I said, most of the
cast is getting back together. And uh
you know, when I watched the trailer for
it, I was like, h this is really
ironically freaky that they put this in
the movie and this is really
inappropriate.
It's borderline
pedophilia, but then like wrapped up,
sugarcoated in this comedy, and so
therefore, nobody notices it. But I
think once I point it out to you guys,
you'll notice it. But first, I want to
look at the original Freaky Friday
because a similar thing was happening in
the original Freaky Friday where again,
it's sugarcoated pedophilia. Again, who
is a target audience for this movie? A
lot of teenagers. That's right. And so
they see this kind of stuff and seeds
are being planted. So, let's take a look
at the first Freaky Friday. As they get
to school, Anna asks Tess to play nice
with Jake while they're in this
situation, threatening her that if she
doesn't, she will break up with Ryan.
Wo! Go, Anna!
Oh my. Uh, can I go? Why? What do you
got to give him a chance? That is the
last thing I'm going to give him. Just
look at him. You don't even know it.
While Tess walks down the unfamiliar
school halls, she gets chatted up by
Jake. And even if Tess attempts to keep
the conversation going, she doesn't
really follow whatever it is that he's
saying. On the other hand, Ryan is
attempting to kiss Anna in Tess's body,
but manages to dodge it when he drops
her off at her place.
Can you guys see what I mean? Yeah, I
see what you mean. Like the older adult
is going after the, you know, underage
teen
cuz they're flip-flopped. Mhm. Yeah.
Yeah. But then like nobody knows other
than the two women that are that are
swapped, right? Mhm. Okay. Nobody knows.
Nobody knows. Yeah. But it also like I
think encourages or at least plants the
seed that this is just what teenagers
do, right? They're just going to be out
there and, you know, be attracted
sexually to each other in this way. I
just find it weird that and I understand
like what Felipe is saying like the
other people don't know. So, it's not
outright like the adults are knowing
what they're doing. I can see that. And
but however, it is being set up as like,
hey, the adult is trying to kiss the
teenager and the teenager is like, oh,
this is weird because she's a teenager.
And you'll see in a second how it gets
weirder when the um mom mom's body,
daughter's inside the body, right?
daughter's mind, mom's body is now
trying to go with the daughter's
boyfriend, and the boyfriend is actually
now attracted to the mom, thinking it's
the mom. So, things get a little
confusing weird. Be confusing. Yeah. But
if there were no body swapping in the
real in the real world, that gets you in
trouble if you're an adult going after
students. Yeah. And we've seen people
who have made the news for that. That's
true. It is true. Yeah. I I I just
personally think like if I were a
teenager, especially not growing up
Christian, I would not think anything of
it. But I think seeds are being planted
in your mind. Yeah. Little seeds toward
hm you know maybe this is something that
uh that could be considered. So um now
here is the mom. She is again this is
Anna daughter Anna inside the mom's
body. And Anna likes this guy this
character played by Chad Michael Murray.
Anna in the mom's body comes to a cafe
and she sees you know Chad Michael
Murray's character. Anna as a teenager
was always had a crush on him and but he
never really had an interest for her.
But now all of a sudden he meets her
inside her mom's body thinking it's the
mom and let's look take a look at what
happens. Heads to a cafe after the
interview where she runs into Jake and
shares a cup of coffee with him. Not
smart Anna. Let's remember you're
trapped in your mother's body. They once
again get to sharing their music tastes
and discuss their mutual love for Hit Me
Baby one more time. Let's be real. Who
could ever hate such an iconic hit? Anna
has to hurry to her rehearsal dinner,
much to Jake's disappointment, who is
now head over heels for Anna. But in
Tess's body, then I guess we're in a
pickle. Creepy and disgusting. No
thanks. Oh,
I love this song. Am I so lame that I
would love baby one more time?
[Music]
Hit me baby one more time.
Really? I just Please, just please
let me at least give you a ride.
Okay.
[Music]
My loneliness
is killing me. And
I must confess I still believe
[Music]
awkward. You notice that everyone was
like, "What is happening here?"
How inappropriate it is to be normal.
Yeah, but you're also putting this idea
I think you break down society when you
show them this relationship over and
over and over. At first it's weird and
then you're putting that in the public's
mind. Yeah. Yeah. I agree with you. And
and the thing is that Hollywood is not
just sticking with just one movie. Like
it's putting this idea out over and over
and over again like you said so
eventually you just accept it, right?
And and we know there's a whole
pedophilia agenda going on out there,
right? We know unfortunately there's a
lot of pedophilia going on in the upper
classes of Hollywood. I mean the age
range of something is illegal. I mean
there's a reason why that's illegal.
Mhm. Mhm. Oh, it's a bit weird. Wow.
Okay. So, I'd probably have a very
similar reaction if I saw them at a
cafe. In fact, I'd probably call the
police at that point. But, uh you know
what's even weirder? So, here he is
couple years later and he's talking
about how apparently Lindsay Lohan had
never kissed any guy before before this
movie and so she had to kiss him. And
so, uh, look at what happened on the
set. This is really strange to me, dude.
I just made out with Jam Lee Curtis.
Nope. Our eyes and ears aren't deceiving
us. That was Chad Michael Murray
confessing he once played tonsil hockey
with Jamie Lee Curtis. The Riverdale
star dropped the bombshell on Busy
Tonight Thursday, revealing that the Big
Smooch went down in 2003 when Jaime and
Chad were filming the Disney flick
Freaky Friday with Lindsay Lohan. Chad
says Lindsay Lohan had never been kissed
and was nervous about locking lips for
the cameras. That's when Jamie stepped
in to um save the day. I was um Lindsay
Lohan's first kiss and uh Jamie Lee
Curtis was there and she was trying to
kind of settle the situation cuz
Lindsay's nerves were a little bit you
know all over the place as you would
assume right your first kiss you're like
16 years old at the time Lindsay was 16,
Chad was 21 and Jamie was drum roll
please 44. Jamie's like all right get in
get in my trailer. Come on. So we go and
we sit in Jaime's trailer and she's
talking to to Lindsay trying to get her
to it's very just you know just kiss
him. Come on just give him a pop kiss.
It's no big deal. Let's break the ice
now. She goes, "Oh, come on." And she
just grabs me by the back of the head
and makes out with me in the mouth. And
Jamie Curtis. Yeah. And I'm going
and at this point I went, "Dude, I just
made out with Jamie F. This is crazy.
This is great." And and then that was
it. Wow. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That is uh
really wild. I love that story. Do we
love this story? Do we? It seems all
kinds of weird. It's just yesterday was
freaky. And I mean I I I see your mom
and I like her. I mean I like her like
but you know I mean like as your mom
what? Yeah. Admitting to your girlfriend
that you like her mom is kind of messed
up. These things just get weirder, man.
Like this happened on the set. Like just
just the fact that this grown woman is I
I know he was of age. He was they said
21 at somewhere else I read 22. Um he
was of age sure but that's like what
you're like this old person. Sorry but
and then you just go and like come here
and you just like if that was a male
doing it to a female you would instantly
get like arrested or something you know
and and then like in front of let's say
a minor. The minor's in the trailer with
you guys. Like what on earth? It's
probably part of her contract though. I
mean, I'm sure she wasn't going in that
completely blind. It was like what? I
had to kiss somebody. Like no, she knew.
Probably knew and was building up to
that because she's a minor. I would hope
that it would be in a contract. Like you
it would have to be. I mean, but yes, to
to kiss on set, but to get pulled into a
trailer and like you're just nobody else
watching. nobody else watching and it's
just like this older lady kissing your
co-star in front of you like making out
like French kissing in front of you is
really strange. It is very strange.
Yeah. And like this is how you kiss
someone. Okay.
Yeah. I think technically before they're
18 years old, I think you have to have
your parent on set and the parent
technically should be within eyes range
of that child of all times. I think
that's what's supposed to happen. Does
it always happen? Probably not. Probably
not. Yeah. Yeah. So, you know, um I
think this is kind of showing you the
unfortunate culture of Hollywood. Um but
then now you have Freakier Friday, which
is the remake. Like I said, uh there's
remake or is it a like a sequel? Sequel.
You're right. It's a sequel. So, in this
case, uh Lindsay Lohan, obviously she's
an adult now, so she's all grown up and
her character is is grown up. She has a
teenage daughter herself and she is
going to body swap with her teenage
daughter. How old is she? The teenage
daughter cuz I'm wondering 44. Yeah,
she's actually 47. The same age as Jamie
Lee Curtis was. Yeah, probably close to
It's actually close to that. Yeah, I
think she might be now she does that
with her daughter. Yes, but in the show,
but uh Jimmy Lee Curtis is still in the
movie. Yes, she's now the grandma. Oh,
and so Lindsay Lohan's character is
getting married to a new guy, right? If
they have the grandma swatch places, I I
don't want to be in this part of
conversation anymore.
So, so Lindsay Loa's character is
getting married to a new guy, and the
new guy has a daughter that you see on
the right, and she's has some British
accent or something like that, which
everybody finds annoying. And the
grandma Jamie Lee Curtis on the left
here. She's body swapping with her
future what? Stepg granddaughter I guess
what you call it. So So that's how the
body swaps are happening. So basically
the teenagers become the adults and the
adults become the teenagers. Okay. Wait,
so the grandma really is technically the
teenager? Yes. Yeah. Oh no, this just
got really weird.
So yeah, it's it's weird because in the
first movie the you know she was body
swapping and she was going after Chad
Michael Murray's character kind of kind
of kind of not but as a mother to a
teenager now we're talking about
grandmother grandmother cougar and it's
going to happen it's going to happen
again. Watch this clip. Nice car. It's
totally mine. She thinks you're cute. I
do not. Yes. I do. She so does. Dr.
Coleman. Oh my god. That's my therapist.
[Applause]
Yeah, it's freaky. It is really freaky.
It's freakier. Yeah, she should not be
wearing clothing like that, too, as a
grandma. Well, but think about it. They
did a body swap. So, now it's a teenager
inside the body. It's It's the
stepdaughter inside her body. And the
stepdaughter probably dressed her up
like that, you know?
And the and the teenagers are like,
"Cool, let's go take the car for a
ride." And then she sees the boy she
liked, but then it's like again, it's
planting a seed. Mhm. There's a grandma
flirting with a teenage boy. Right.
Right. That's weird. Yeah. And you see
again the same reaction. The first movie
it was like everybody in the cafe was
like, "What?" And in this movie, it's
like the dad's like, "What are you
doing? You're my therapist."
Now, um, it's interesting. I was
thinking about other movies that have
kind of done a similar thing. Body
swapping and maybe like where people
don't know who you really are and they
have this inappropriate relationships.
Remember Face Off? Face Off. Yeah, that
was um John Travolta. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
They did that. They did that too. They
swapped. Mhm. But it was But that was
like a different surgical kind of thing,
I think. Yeah. Yeah. Very different than
this. Yeah. Has anybody ever seen 17
again? You have, right?
Matthew Perry, Zack Efron, and Leslie
Man. It's kind of the big cast in here.
So, I remember when I was a teenager, um
I watched this movie with my mom, went
to the movie theater. I was like, I want
to watch Zack Afron because this is like
one of his first movies he he did after
High School Musical. So, in this movie,
Matthew Perry's character, he's a dad.
Um he his wife is Leslie Man. They um
are going through a divorce. They're not
doing too well. And it's kind of odd,
but he drives across a bridge, sees his
old man, which now I realize was
actually called his spirit guide, which
is super newagy. Okay. He almost looked
like an angel, like an older man. He he
jumps off the bridge. Matthew Perry's
like, "What is happening?" And he falls
off the bridge and all of a sudden he is
17 again. So he is in a 17-year-old
body, but in today's day and age, right?
He doesn't go back in time. And so, um,
he looks exactly like he was 17 when his
wife first, uh, Exactly. Exactly. So,
she recognizes him and she's like, "You
look so much like my husband when he was
younger, you know." And so, he has a
pseudo name. His best friend, who is
also a grown man, of course, is he's
they're faking that that's his dad so he
can get into high school, kind of check
on his kids, but also relive his life.
and he tries to intervene in his
marriage um even though now he's in his
younger body, right? So that's kind of
what's happening. So in this clip here,
here he is with his wife, but he is 17.
So his wife doesn't know who he actually
is. He thinks that it's she thinks this
is his her son's friend. She has a son
and her and her son made friends with
him. Yeah. But bottom line is she
doesn't know this is actually her
husband and he is 17. Try me.
Why did you pick that song? Oh, I don't
know. It just um kind of spoke to me. H
that's funny. That's a song that my
husband and I danced to at our wedding.
H a man of good taste. Do you want me to
show you some dance moves? I would love
to see some that I learned at my
wedding. Great. Yeah. Okay. You stand
here like that? Okay. Like that. I'll
stand here. No, you stand right there.
Right there. Right there. Okay. Ready?
So, you go right foot back and then left
foot back and then quick right, left,
right, left, right, and then right. Oh,
that was good. Left, right, left, right.
That's good. Wow, that was really good.
You're picking that up pretty quickly.
You mentioned your husband. Mhm. Do you
think you guys are ever going to get
back together? Um, no.
Why are you so sure? Maybe there's
something he could do to fix things. I
love my husband and care about him, but
but sometimes that just is not enough.
Oh, he blew it.
jump.
[Music]
You don't understand.
Turn your head.
Huh? Yeah.
Hi, Alex.
I'm your mom.
I'm Alex's mom, Mark. Yeah.
Your date is here, huh?
Front door.
She's nervous. It's creepy, right? A
little bit. She's so old. It's like
dance with all your friends moms. Pretty
much same setup, right? Mhm. Yeah. like
like clearly she doesn't know that
that's her husband and but we know as
the viewers. So again there's like it's
like sugarcoated. It's not like asking.
Yeah. But she's you know like falling in
love with a 17-year-old with a minor
heart break.
All right. I can do this.
[Music]
Hurry.
There are conventional ways of sharing
the gospel, but some may need a
different way of doing things. Um, never
mind. A way that gets the message out
with confidence.
Wow, cool shirt. What's it mean? Oh,
thank you. You know, we're all made with
a unique fingerprint, but we're all
God's artwork. Wow. Where'd you get it?
Lightwear. Wear your witness.
So you you would have seen Big. Yes. Did
you ever see Big? No. Did you? No. Okay.
Tom Hanks movie from like what the 80s.
That was his like breakout role. I think
he had only been in the TV show before
that. Yeah. So basic premise he is
um he's a kid. He wants to be big. He
goes to this m well machine I guess at a
machine. Yeah. fortune teller machine at
a carnival. He makes a wish that he
would be big and it comes true. It's
like a dark and stormy night. You know,
something it's like something mysterious
and supernatural happens and essentially
he wakes up big. And so then he's grown
up as an adult. You know, his mom
doesn't recognize him. You know, he has
to get out of the house. He has to go
get a job. All this kind of stuff. And
he just acts like a big kid because he's
still mentally the age that he was when
he made the wish.
and he eventually winds up in a
relationship
and but with an adult with an adult
and I remember seeing this as as a kid.
I don't know how old I was but you know
when you're younger I remember seeing
that and it's implied not shown I think
it's PG or something.
It's implied that they have a night
together.
And I remember thinking, wait, he's not
he's not old enough to do that. He's a
kid. Did you Did you have that thought
when you saw that? And it's just like
that's there's something wrong with
that, right? But it's this, you know,
real for the time and compared to a lot
of today's stuff, it would be considered
relatively tame, right? As far as a
movie, it's like PG. There's not like a
bunch of language in it. There's not a
bunch of violence in it. There's it's
like, you know, clean by today's
standards. I say that, you know, like
loosely. But there are these themes like
the the fortune teller and the, you
know, basically sleeping with his lady
as a kid. But the reason that we have
that statutory law is because of the
mind. So, it's kind of like blurring
that line with something that is clearly
illegal even if the body's ready. Does
that make sense? Like a body, a woman's
body can is ready for reproduction at
like 13, 12. It doesn't mean mentally
she's ready for that. Right. Right. And
they're almost putting this rubber stamp
of approval on the body instead of the
mind. We're talking about blurry lines.
I'm thinking here like I'm not sure how
blurry this line is but yeah poor things
is not as blurry I guess of of
you it's more clear I guess right the
concept more open yeah they're not
hiding as as much we we actually did a
live on uh on about poor things a while
ago and this actually won an Oscar do
you remember a little bit about this
movie like it was pretty crazy no my
hard drive's getting full deleted
useless things pro probably a good
thing. Yeah. So from from what I
understand this movie the line is not
blurry on a lot of things not only that
you know the mind of a child and all
that but also like the types of
relationship she actually gets in like
they actually have full on uh sex scenes
with with uh
this is a kid but it's on a on a on a on
a grown body adult body but child mind
but in from I I didn't see the movie but
I think the the sex scenes are actually
not even onens censored there. There's
like surpris like full bull on
pornography. Wow. Crazy. So with a
child's child. Yeah. Yeah. So So uh I
have a clip here from the while back
when we did this live and that kind of
explains the story line and why there's
a problem with this. So this movie
particularly the story is that there's
this girl her name is um Bella which
would just means beautiful and her name
is last name is Bella Baxter right and
so Bella is uh she wants to commit
suicide okay so she tries to kill
herself but she is she's pregnant she
has a fetus in her womb and this doctor
gets her body and he takes out the fetus
and puts it inside her brain. So now
there's an adult body with a child brain
that which is what we're also seeing on
the movie poster. Of course, once Bella
makes it out into the world, she does so
just having discovered the joys of
physical pleasure. This was something
she discovered with the help of an
apple. There she is sleeping with grown
men. And there's even a clip where this
guy who has kidnapped her, who has
fallen in love with her, takes her and
she's on a boat and he's like, "Hey, you
know, you want to take this breeze and
cuz you're on a ship. You want to take
it inside the room?" Like she is
sleeping with him when she has a baby's
brain in her mind. She is technically
still a child, right? And then she's
also there is this other character that
she was once married to. I guess she
just forgot or something like that. His
name is Alfie. And Alfie turns out is
the dad of the fetus that was inside her
belly which now has been put in her
brain and so they are now married.
That's incest, right? So that Nat's now
even inching into even further things
that I think are very disturbing and we
need to talk about these things. That's
well bizarre. It's more disturbing than
I thought. Yeah, it's so bizarre. And
and speaking of incest in 17 A again,
you know, Zack Efron's character is 17
again goes to the school and so he's
trying to he's trying to help his
daughter uh get away from this football
player and uh that relationship and so
his daughter now falls in love with Zack
Efron's character being her dad, but is
you know him 17 again and she actually
tries to have sex with the dad in a
17-year-old body. Now he refuses. He's
like, "This is inappropriate." Blah,
blah, blah.
But still, yeah. What are you putting
out there? Right. So, same thing in Poor
Things. And then, do you guys remember
the curious case of Benjamin Button?
Never saw it, but I never seen it. Never
saw it. You've never seen it. That was
when he actually got younger, I think.
Yes. Yeah. He was like instead of
getting old, it's like he started out
old and then he went the other way.
Interesting. He was born inside and with
a baby's
body, but the body was old and wrinkled
like a grandpa, like it was about to
die. But in his mind, he is young. Like
his mind, he is a baby. And as he grows
up, his mind gets older, but the body
gets younger. So, it's like reversed
aging, basically. So, but of course,
there's a love story involved. And uh so
we'll take a look at this clip here
where he meets this girl and he is a
grandpa in his body, but in his mind
he's a child and they go on a date
together. So grandpa goes on a date with
a child. On the same day, Benjamin meets
Daisy, an attractive girl with blue
eyes. They become friends and really
enjoy each other's company. Although
they are almost the same age, to
everyone else, they appeared as a
teenage girl and a balding old man in
glasses. The people around, not knowing
that Benjamin is actually a child, began
criticizing his friendship with Daisy.
And you ought to be ashamed for
yourself. However, Daisy and Benjamin
understand each other perfectly. They
feel mutual attraction and share
secrets. Caroline realizes and finds it
surprising that her dying mother is the
little Daisy from Benjamin's diary. One
day, Queenie allows Benjamin, who is
already 15 years old at that time, to go
for a walk to the port. there. He
accidentally ends up on a ship hired as
a sailor. Captain Mike, who loves to
drink, enjoys talking to the old man.
Benjamin's attraction to Daisy grows
stronger. One early morning, he takes
Daisy to the boat and asks his new
friend, Captain Mike, to take them for a
ride along the river. Despite the risk
of losing his license, Captain Mike
agrees and his guests aboard enjoy a
romantic morning on the river. Noticing
the changes happening to his body,
Benjamin starts to suspect that he is
getting younger. One day, he decides to
start his own journey in life and set
off on a long voyage. As they said
goodbye, Daisy asks him to send
postcards from every place he would
visit. Benjamin and Daisy have now
parted ways. Daisy enters ballet school
and begins her career as a dancer.
Meanwhile, Benjamin travels the world on
a boat with his friend, Captain Mike,
and as promised, he sends Daisy
postcards from different parts of the
world. Soon after Benjamin's return,
Daisy also arrives at the nursing home.
Their reunion was joyful and friendly,
but Benjamin no longer looks at Daisy as
just a childhood friend. He sees her as
a beautiful woman. Daisy marries a good
man and lives a happy life with him. One
day, Benjamin returns to see his family.
He looks like he is 20 years old and
both he and Daisy realize that they have
made the right decision by parting ways.
Yet, they still feel drawn to each
other. I will never stop loving you.
They make love in a hotel room and then
part ways again for many years. They
meet each other again when Daisy is
already an elderly woman and Benjamin
looks like a teenager. He lives in the
nursing home because he is becoming
scenile and forgetting everything. This
time Daisy can no longer leave him
alone. Her daughter has moved out and
her husband has passed away. She
dedicates all her time to the boy who is
actually an old man. Benjamin continues
to grow younger and forgets almost
everything. Daisy cares for him like a
child, which is how others see him.
Isn't that weird? Just get odd. It is.
So yeah, like again
in the beginning she's having a
relationship, she's a child and then she
having a relationship with a grown man
with a grandpa when I know in their
minds they're like similar age. But if I
were an actor and I had to like look
through the script and play this role,
I'm like, "So you're telling me that I'm
going to dress up like an old man and
I'm going to be on a date, a romantic
date with my girlfriend who is a child?"
Yeah. No thanks. Yeah. very weird. And
then toward the end again, like they're
still in love, but then she like nurses
him and stuff and he's a child. Yeah.
But she still sees him as her romantic
partner that she's always been in love
with, right? So yeah, it's weird because
it's a fantasy. Obviously, I don't think
this is actually based on any sort of
reality. I don't think there's anybody
that's had this experience in life. So
yeah, it's just putting the idea or
imagery out there that, you know, it
doesn't really matter. It's all about
what's in the mind, right? Age isn't a
barrier to love and you know all those
things. Yeah. Yep. Well, the Bible has
some things to say about this. Uh Isaiah
5:20 says, "Woe to those who call evil
good and good evil, who put darkness for
light and light for darkness, who put
bitter for sweet and sweet for bitter."
So, you know, we have to be careful with
these kind of things. When we watch
these kind of movies, we're
participating in what this verse speaks
against. So, we have to be careful with
that. Mhm. So, let's go back to Freakier
Friday. Let's bring it all back around.
Uh, another point that I thought was
interesting about Freakier Friday is
that, you know, in the first movie, they
had um the Chinese restaurant with the
fortune cookies and that's how the body
swap happened. Well, they took it up a
notch. The Lindsay Lohan's character is
getting married. So, she has her
bachelorette party and they have a
fortune teller there and she's the one
who's causing the body swap. My
bachelorette party will be good bonding
for everyone. You two are called to be
family. Yeah, right. Don't remind me.
You've walked in each other's path. You
learned a lesson. A lesson that may
serve you again. Okay, that's enough.
Thank you very much. One more thing.
Right over there is a QR code that you
can tip me with. Yeah. All C9 triangle
and crystals everywhere. I mean, you
should expect that at a fortune teller's
place. So, right. But like they put that
in the movie, you know? They were like,
"No, no, no. We're not going to do
fortune cookies now. We're going to take
it up a notch. We're just going to go
full on, you know, magic and and new age
and everything like blatant, you know."
Yeah. which is something that they've
been actually putting more and more
prevalent kind of ideas into that. um
the the mother of do you remember that
elemental
sorry elemental or whatever like that
the mom's job was a fortune teller and
you know by just kind of throwing these
things in kids programs it's like makes
you not think it's such a horrible thing
normalize it and again teenagers watch
this kind of stuff right like I mean
might as well if you're already trying
to get teenagers used to pedophilia just
throw some magic in there too and just
make them go sink their ship I mean
magic's been put everywhere from you
know it's like magic is is bigger than
pedophilia in movies at this point. So
there's a lot of things in our world
that we think are normal and they're
not. Mhm. Mhm. You know, they're
normalized because of sin, but they're
not normal. Right. Right. Yeah. Yep. The
Bible speaks very clearly against these
kind of things in Deuteronomy. We use
this verse over and over again. There
shall not be found among you anyone who
makes his son or his daughter pass
through the fire or one who practices
witchcraft or a soothsayer or one who
interprets omens or a sorcerer or one
who conjur spells or a medium or a
spiritist or one who calls up the dead.
For all who do these things are an
abomination to the Lord. Keith, how do
you understand abomination from the
Bible? It's a very strong word. You
know, it's it's one when God uses the
word abomination, he's really saying, "I
hate this thing."
That's right. And why, you've talked
about this many times, but why why is
this particular thing like witchcraft
and sorcery? Why is that such an
abomination to God? Yeah. It's it's an
impersonation, I think, of of God's
servants. So, his prophets, the Bible
says the Lord God does nothing and
unless he reveals his secrets to his
servants, the prophets. That's Amos
chapter 3, I think. And if that's God's
chosen method to communicate from these
times, of course we have the Bible now
to help with us, but if that was his
method to communicate to his people and
you introduce another voice, how do they
know the difference? So I think the
Bible says, you know, uh if they speak
not according to this word, there's no
light in them. that passage from Isaiah
8 um 20 when you look at the verses that
precede it 19 is talking about
witchcraft and sorcery.
So you know it says don't go to the
wizards that meep that peep and mutter
should not a people seek unto its god.
Mhm. So it's in it's in that context
that God is saying like look don't don't
go seek into these other things. They
don't they don't speak according to my
word. There's no light in that. So, this
is a counterfeit. That's why God takes
it so strongly because how would how
would we know the difference and that's
why I think we have the written word.
It's it's a check and balance, right? If
it doesn't line up with that, then you
know it's not right. Right. Yeah. And
and again, if Kevin Smith, who's a big
director in Hollywood, says most
directors, pretty much all directors,
put their own version of their morality
and values in movies, then somebody on
set is saying, you know what? I want to
put my ideas of magic and sorcery and
witchcraft and Sue saying in this movie.
It's written into the script on purpose.
And by the way, guess who owns this this
movie franchise? These two. Freaky
Friday. Bakery Friday. Yeah. Jamie Lee
Curtis. Disney. Disney. Oh. Mhm. Jaime
Lee Curtis was the one who approached
Disney and said, "Hey, we should do a
sequel, but Disney is the one who put
out puts out the movie." Yeah. Doesn't
surprise me. Disney likes witchcraft. I
mean, it's always been since the
Sorcerers Apprentice, right? Mhm. That's
right. Yeah. I mean, like even since Oh,
yeah. Sorcerers Apprentice, which is
Mickey Mouse. Sorry. Yeah. The original.
Yeah. Matthew 24 12-13 says that because
lawlessness will abound, the love of
many will grow cold, but he who endures
to the end will be saved. We are living
so so so close to the second coming of
Jesus. And and I really want to
encourage people, you know, check out
our playlist on Bible prophecy on our
channel. Um because we are absolutely at
the end of time and if Jesus is coming
soon then we need to be ready for him to
come and we need to have relationship
with Jesus and step away from from
lawlessness and and seek a relationship
with him so that we may be saved because
it's in relationship with Jesus that
we'll be saved. You know, Matthew 7
talks about that there's many people who
call themselves Christians who who do
all these things, but when you don't
have the relationship with him, like a
genuine relationship, we're like, "Lord,
whatever you will tell me, I will do
because I trust in you and because
you're my best friend. You're my
savior." He wants to have a genuine
relationship with you because he wants
to change our lives and hearts for the
better. And that relationship is what he
can then use to say, "I know your heart
is in the right place. and know you want
me. Let's let's let's do this together.
And John 17:15-17
says, I do not pray that you should take
them out of the world, but that you
should keep them from the evil one. They
are not of the world just as I am not of
the world. Sanctify them by your truth.
Your word is truth. Scotty, what does
this verse mean to you when you read
this? I think that it's given you a
window into where to find truth. And you
know it if if if there was no one place
that the truth can be found. Well,
anybody's truth. I mean, you hear that
today. That's your truth. That's my
truth. That's your truth. Um and and and
really, what does that even mean? You
know what I mean? Your truth, your
version. You can make that up. So, I
think the word of God is saying like
here's the here's the thing that you
know right and wrong, left or right. And
you know, that's going to be found in
God's word. Why? Because God's the one
that inspired that thing to be said, not
the man. If you like this video, like,
subscribe, and hit the notification bell
so you know when we launch new videos.
And drop a comment below, and we'll try
to get back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.